like any good detectives on the tail of
a serial killer international experts on
the coronavirus have been called
together for a case conference in the
hope of piecing together vital evidence
it's now been named kovat 19 and top of
the list for those meeting at the World
Health Organization in Geneva will be to
know how many people are at risk people
infected with the virus seemed to pass
it on to two or three others on average
making it twice as infectious as flu
that could mean 60 to 80 percent of the
world's population being infected if the
virus goes unchecked it may come in
several waves over many months or even
years a long drawn-out epidemic with a
lower peak would be easier to manage
than an explosion of cases the w-h-o
also wants to know when people become
infectious currently it believes the
incubation period is anywhere between 1
and 12 and a half days and that people
are a risk to others before they develop
symptoms but when some people may not
show symptoms at all or only have a mild
infection that would allow more rapid
spread through a population there's also
the question of super spreaders Steve
Walsh the Brighton case seems to have
infected 11 others scientists believe
part of it is down to biology some
people's immune systems shut down the
infection but the virus is still exhaled
in every breath but is also about
opportunity mixing with lots of people
at close quarters now any detective will
want a good idea on who the next victim
will be and it's the same with
scientists so who is at risk
currently the death rate in China is 2.4
percent but that will include people who
are infected before doctors knew what
they were dealing with so the long term
death rate in countries with good
critical care facilities could be much
lower so far all the evidence points to
older people and those with underlying
health issues such as respiratory or
heart disease being at high risk of
needing medical care but at this stage
scientists are still getting to grips
with a new virus and making hard
predictions on what happens next is
impossible